nathan of aldi his last start against
tampa bay was august 11th
red sox got him a ton of runs but he
went seven strong
three hit innings one of his best
outings of the year
that's right back through the middle we
had ivaldi ducking at a base head into
center
so brandon lau is aboard to start this
one
slide to center field by franco [ __ ]
backing up to make the play
and one man gone
a little chopper
right over the head of the runner ours
will flip to first down the second moves
lao
and a pop-up around third there's
debbers
and he's got it
for the tampa bay rays here tonight it's
going to be left-hander shane mcclanahan
two starts against the red sox that last
start took an l didn't get a lot of help
the race got shut out in that game
eduardo rodriguez that was the game that
he threw so well
skied into center field
or go
in and now he backs up a couple steps to
make the grab
one away
on the ground third into the glove of
wendell
that's out number two
and walked him
99 miles an hour but he puts him on red
sex have their first base runner
and base hit
toward the alley martinez racing for
third
debra is gonna base it first down third
and two down and the pitch slice to
right for his chance for low back into
his left makes the catches first big
league put out ends the first inning
here's g-man choi he's been a red sox
nemesis
just came off the il today for the third
time
3-2 got him
joy
on kind of a high split goes down first
k for native aldi
oh yeah up in the zone it was a split up
in the zone he couldn't check that swing
i tell you what that ball up there is
hard to hit no matter what it is split
finger fastball you can't get to that
pitch
i fly headed toward the wall backing up
santana though and well short of it
they'll make the catch
a little trickler
and well he's going to be quick throws
oh nice play and did he get to that fast
and through a strike
making his major league debut at the
plate 3-2
and that's a fastball inside so he draws
a walk in his first big league played
appearance
and the runner takes off in their head
first stolen base to josh lowe after the
walk
steals his way into scoring position
perfect in the stolen base department at
triple a and one of one in the big
league well the jump and he is a long
strider with really good speed he got
that bag it wasn't even close
and that will be ball four the breaking
ball there three and one to issue the
walk
shout out to left center on his horse
it's kiki runs it down what a nice play
on the running track runners have to get
back
wasn't that nice to see
and a swing and a mess to put him away
a little wild in the inning but he
survives it so with one out and one on
here's jd martinez
lifted into right center field
there is margaux making the catch
margot in right center field right in
front of the bullpen made the catch made
contact and held on did he rob him i
mean the wall is short there this is a
slider by mcclanahan and we know that jd
martinez a lot of power the other way
let's see how close it was oh yeah that
ball gets over the wall i mean this is
this is going it's a two run shot or not
austin meadows leading off
down he goes he strikes out meadows one
out
swing and a miss spun him around and he
struck him out back to back hayes for
nate
man he just basically tossed it down the
line
up against the tarp here's the throw
[Applause]
oh my
well guess who
hunter renfro says how do you do
hunter renfro scooped it up over by the
tarp and threw a perfect laser
to the shortstop iglesias to tag out
margot trying to stretch a single into a
double and in the inning bottom third of
the order do here joey wendell
and he puts away wendell here
and in fact he has struck out four of
the last five rays yeah look at this
[ __ ] starts middle and just breaks all
the way to his back foot that's some
serious depth on that pitch
yeah that might be the best pitch he's
thrown tonight
now josh lowe left-handed batter walked
his first big league played appearance
tap to the left side gonna be a tough
play with his speed and no throw there
it is a base hit for josh lowe
celebration there by his mother wendy
and so josh lowe picks up his first big
league hit
the infield hit
caught on and missed he puts away zadino
two strikeouts in the inning
four in the last two frames
strikes him out with a curveball he
strikes out three in the inning
scoreless
middle of hitting five here
he lines it into left and
that ball caught by austin meadows
and a swing at a medicine boy
i'll tell you he made quick work
of arouse
boom boom and boom here comes the
curveball look how long that's in the
zone for and arahu's out there just kind
of fishing for it
and uh
fastball line to left caught on the
track and left by meadows so five
innings for mcclanahan
and now it's catrice
that's on the ground and by
joy into right field and to make the
pick up is low that on an o2 pitch and
rinpro
goes the other way with a lead-off
single
ground ball third wendell loud one first
base two around the horn
5-4-3 on the double play off the bat of
j.d martinez
and he gets him
swinging in a miss
nathan of aldi returns for the seventh
ladder
he's up and running and he gets the out
at first base
wow
he goes sprawling after it he used all
of that big frame of his to get the out
at first beat fairbanks will be pitcher
number three for the raise and a call
third strike on the corner at 99.
and he got him he goes up with 98 hard
stuff again up back-to-back strikeouts
2-2 and he gets a swing and miss on the
slider fairbanks strikes out the side no
runs in yet and richard's trying to make
sure it stays that way here in the
eighth and here comes juana franco's
going over three
and there is ball four and franco
reaches
so that extends the odd base streak
38 games now for franco
with the walk in the eighth inning of
this game use it first lao moves up to
second we'll go first wow at second
richards against cruz
[Music]
and a base head into center field
hernandez with the pickup and the throw
will be cut off and the rays take the
lead
bruce pitch cruz drives it into center
lau scores in its one-nothing tampa bay
run for tonight one for three a single
sox looking for some magic
down a run
high fly ball left field that's way way
up there and there's your magic baby
that's gone there it is
he left that pitch out over the plate
like i said
took total advantage of it
hunter renfrow number 27
and he's put the red sox in front
with an absolute bomb at fenway that's
el robles his job is to push this one
into the win column which would
certainly be the most important moment
of his red sox career
change
[Applause]
razer down to their final opportunity
here is joey wendell
fly ball that one headed for the alley
santana with a dive he can't get it it
rolls behind him renfro backs him up
windows heading for third
here's the throw the tag
when the ball game is over
are you kidding me
red sox win it
oh my goodness
wendell out at third base
trying to sprint to third he is cut down
and the sox win a thriller at fenway
park